die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin schönen montagabend ihnen
alle mit mir im studio für den sport ist
norbert könig und du hast später mehr
zur vorfreude auf das zweite em spielen
deutschlands fußballerin absolut daher
winkt schon das viertelfinale schon
genannt und das haben wir heute außerdem
apple in der röhre wegen der geplanten
wartung liefert die pipeline nord stream
1 kein gas mehr jetzt fragen sich alle
wie es in zehn tagen weitergeht
bombardierung welle in der ost ukraine
die regierung in kiel fürchtet eine
großoffensive russlands
hitzeglocke
südwesteuropa portugal kämpft mit
waldbränden und einer extrem wetterlage
die uns ab ende der woche bevorstehen
soll
seit heute schaut deutschland in die
röhre in die leere wenn man so will seit
heute fließt wartungs bedingt für
mindestens zehn tage kein russisches gas
mehr durch die wichtigste pipeline nord
stream 1 bleibt es bei zehn tagen oder
müssen wir uns auf einen winter mit
extremen engpässen einstellen alles ist
möglich sagt dazu wirtschaftsminister
habe ich das meiste gas in deutschland
verbrauchen industrie und gewerbe im
vergangenen jahr waren das genau 50
prozent
danach kamen die privaten haushalte mit
31 12 prozent wurden für die
stromversorgung und sieben für fernwärme
genutzt aktuell geht der verbrauch
übrigens spürbar unter vor allem bei der
industrie und der stromversorgung
elisabeth schmidt über die sorge ums gas
in normalen zeiten würde heute
vermutlich niemand auf diese anlage
schauen lubmin mecklenburg vorpommern
seit dem morgen hat russland hier an der
nord stream-pipeline das gas abgestellt
zehn tage technik-check routine
eigentlich
wir haben aus russland ganz
unterschiedliche signale es gibt
sprecher des kremls die sagen in
kombination mit der 7 turbine man könne
wieder wesentlich mehr liefern es gab
aber auch sehr martialische ansagen aus
dem kreml ehrlich gesagt es weiß keiner
seit mitte juni kommen nur noch 40
prozent erdgas über die röhre nach
deutschland russland begründet das mit
einer fehlenden gasturbine von siemens
jetzt aber geliefert wird viele
vorgeschobene gründe sagt
wirtschaftsminister habeck heute in prag
mehrere europäische länder wollen sich
per abkommen künftig gegenseitig bei der
gasversorgung unterstützen wir brauchen
gas aus norwegen wir brauchen gas aus
den niederlanden wir brauchen die
importe im südeuropäischen raum gekommen
in dieser situation nur weiter wenn wir
uns gegenseitig helfen alle seien jetzt
gefragt denn in deutschland sind die
gasspeicher erst zu knapp 65 prozent
gefüllt derzeit reduzierte die industrie
ihren gasverbrauch schon massiv wir sind
schon bei über zehn prozent
verbrauchsreduktion da ist deutlich mehr
drin auch kurzfristig für verbraucher
wird es vor allem teuer dieser
energieversorger in hannover erhöht
seine tarife für die glas
grundversorgung ab oktober um 70 prozent
und das unternehmen arbeitet derzeit
notfallpläne aus sollte russland gar
kein gas mehr liefern dann sind zuerst
die kunden dran deren verträge es
zulassen dass sie abgeschaltet werden
das heißt die sich freiwillig dazu
gemietet habe dann kommen die
sogenannten nicht geschützten kunden und
ganz zum schluss im allerletzten fall
sind die geschützten kunden dran das
sind die privathaushalte das sind
krankenhäuser becker alles hängt davon
ab ob hier in einer guten woche wieder
russisches pipeline gas ankommt es sind
eben keine normalen zeiten
wir gehen nach moskau zu film liefert
russland weiter gas oder nicht dazu bei
uns große unsicherheit wie blickt man
denn filme im kreml auf die situation
ja diese deutsche unsicherheit darüber
ob nord stream eins nach der wartung
wieder ans netz gehen wird die wird hier
in den russischen talkshows geradezu
genüsslich ausgebreitet und sie wird im
internet verhöhnt deutschland wirkt
schwach russland hingegen stark da hat
wladimir putin doch einen ersten erfolg
schon erzielen können der kreml-chef
wird außerdem darauf spekulieren dass es
in der folge zu hitzigen diskussionen in
deutschland kommt zum beispiel darüber
ob man nord stream zwei nicht doch in
betrieb nehmen sollte auch wenn das eine
weitere schwächung der ukraine bedeuten
würde oder dass streit aufkommt zwischen
denjenigen die weiter an den russland
sanktionen festhalten wollen und
denjenigen die ein ende dieser sanktion
befürworten werden
und insgesamt ist es so dass das ja
nicht nur in deutschland diskutiert wird
sondern dass in vielen westlichen
ländern eine nervosität zu spüren ist
angesichts der hohen energiepreise
wladimir putin der
schätzt diese signale sehr und achtet da
sehr genau darauf er will wissen wo tun
sich womöglich risse auf in der
entschlossenheit und in der
geschlossenheit wie lange muss russland
dem sanktionsdruck überhaupt standhalten
danke für die einordnung nach moskau für
begann das fragen zu einem möglichen
russischen gasstopps können sie dem chef
der bundesnetzagentur stellen gleich um
halb acht bei zdf heute live zu sehen
auf unseren social media kanälen und in
der zdf- heute- app und dort ist dann
auch nachzulesen welche bedeutung die
pipeline nord stream 1 für deutschlands
gasversorgung hat
mit massiven raketen- und panzerbeschuss
auch auf zivile ziele setzen russische
truppen ihre offensive im osten und
südosten der ukraine fort der
ukrainische generalstab sprach von einer
regelrechten bombardierung welle und sie
darin anzeichen für eine bevorstehende
großoffensive unter anderem besonders
betroffen ist die stadt charkiw im
nordosten volker dutschek berichtet
mehr als vier monate krieg katharina
schewtschenko nahezu unbeschadet
überlebt doch dann am morgen der
raketeneinschlag die druckwelle zerstört
ihre wohnungen tragkraft und die letzte
hoffnung auf ein ruhiges leben in hohem
alter
ich saß am tisch und habe was
geschrieben
und plötzlich ich weiß gar nicht genau
wie flug das fenster aus dem rahmen
1,5 millionen menschen haben hier gelebt
bevor der krieg über sie hereinbrach
viele sind geflüchtet aus der stadt nahe
der russischen grenze erst wurden die
russen zurückgeschlagen jetzt rücken sie
wieder vor und machen kein hehl daraus
dass sie kharkiv für immer besetzen
wollen
präsident selen ski hat offenbar seine
strategie geändert er will jetzt den
fokus auf den süden des landes lägen mit
waffen der westlichen staaten will er
dort die besetzten gebiete am schwarzen
meer und asowschen meer zurück erobern
nach angaben von regierungsmitgliedern
hat er die armee angewiesen die
wirtschaftlich wichtigen städte auf der
achse odessa nikolaj persson und milito
pohl nicht kampflos aufzugeben
präsident sie lenski will weitere zivile
opfer russische angriffe vermeiden wegen
der erwarteten neuen angriffswellen
forderte er die bevölkerung in den
städten sa borussia und rassen auf in
den süden zu fliehen notfalls auch in
richtung krim
in rackith hat es heute auch dieses
reifen depot getroffen die russen stehen
im süden und osten vor der stadt die
front rückt wieder näher
dara hassanzadeh ist unterwegs in der
beschossenen stadt kharkiv dara was
pastor erlebt
wir sind heute nach ende des luftalarm
sind die stadt gefahren und haben uns
die stellen an geguckt wo russischer
raketen und artilleriegeschosse
eingeschlagen sind darunter war einen
reifenhandel der man eben in dem beitrag
gesehen hat dort hat ein
artilleriegeschoss ein auto das vorbei
fuhr direkt getroffen vater und sohn
waren sofort tot dann haben wir ein
mietshaus gesehen es wurde sehr zerstört
die an höfer die alona die oft und seit
langem beschuss gewöhnt sind hatte damit
nicht gerechnet denn es geschah am
hellichten tag am späten morgen
dieses vorgehen der russischen armee
städte massiv zu beschießen mit ihrer
artillerie wies auf ein zeichen dafür
dass sie danach vorrücken wollen ob dies
jetzt auch in kharkiv der fall ist wird
sich in den nächsten tagen zeigen vielen
dank nach rajiv dara hassanzadeh
auf der erde leben so viele menschen wie
noch nie aktuell sind es nach zahlen der
vereinten nationen
7,9 milliarden pro jahr werden rund 6 69
millionen babys geboren vor allem im
globalen süden ist die geburtenrate noch
immer besonders hoch allerdings wächst
die zahl der menschen langsamer der
zuwachs lag 2020 zum ersten mal seit
1950 unter einem prozent die
lebenserwartung sei durch corona
weltweit von fast 73 auf
durchschnittlich 71 jahre im vergangenen
jahr gesunken
mitten im sommer erleben wir steigende
corona instanzen und eine sich
verschärfende situation auf
intensivstationen nicht nur in
deutschland und auch deswegen raten eu
behörden jetzt so schnell wie möglich zu
einer zweiten booster impfung für alle
über 60 jährigen und für gesundheitlich
gefährdete menschen ja immer mehr
infektionen bedeuten auch immer mehr
longo wird fälle menschen die also mit
hartnäckigen langzeitfolgen kämpfen es
ist ein vielschichtiges problem zum
einen weil es in vielen teilen des
landes viel zu wenig behandlungsplätze
gibt und zum anderen weil betroffene und
ihre unterschiedlichen beschwerden
häufig nicht ernst genommen werden
sibylle bassler berichtet vor zwei
jahren ist birgit ein corona erkrankt
seitdem so die 29 jährige leide sie an
chronischer erschöpfung komme einfach
nicht mehr auf die beine was ich halt
dieser muskelschmerzen habe im ganzen
körper bei belastungen werden die halt
starker und dadurch habe ich halt kaum
noch muskelkraft der geht wird in der
neurologie des berliner
unfallkrankenhauses behandelt sie ist
eine von über 1000 patienten betreut von
ingo schmehl und seinem team und co
inhalte inzwischen über 200 bekannter
symptome und vordergrund steht aber vor
allem die körperliche und psychische
verminderte belastung im alltag so
unterschiedlich die symptome so
unterschiedlich auch die behandlung der
erkrankten und das mache es auch so
schwierig und aufwändig sagen experten
es gibt verschiedene möglichkeiten in
den therapien die wir nutzen können aber
natürlich gibt es nicht die eine pille
die wir nehmen und eines lankowitz
vorbei für birgit wurde eine speziell
auf sie ausgerichtete therapie
entwickelt dabei sollen der
gleichgewichtssinn
die feinmotorik der krankenschwester
trainiert werden viele haben probleme
beim schreiben herr benutzen des messers
der koordinationsstörungen und wir
können auch gedächtnistraining machen
der geht hat glück dass sie einen
therapieplatz gefunden hat viele
betroffene sind verzweifelt und warten
wochenlang auf therapeutische hilfe
dabei salon cupid längst die neue
volkskrankheit wir haben es hier mit
hunderttausenden vielleicht millionen
menschen zu tun allein in deutschland
die im moment nicht arbeitsfähig sind
umso wichtiger sei es den betroffenen
schnell unbürokratisch und effektiv zu
helfen denn auch bei longo witt zähle
jeder tag
jetzt zur schwierigen tarifrunde in
diesem jahr die preise steigen deutlich
also müssten auch die gehälter deutlich
steigen sagt die ig metall und fordert
acht prozent mehr geld die beschäftigten
bräuchten entlastungen so die
gewerkschaft und stabiler konsum nutze
auch der konjunktur die arbeitgeber
wiesen die forderung als realitätsfern
und verantwortungslos zurück die
tarifverhandlungen für die mehr als 3,8
millionen beschäftigten der branche
beginnen im september
wer ein haus oder eine wohnung besitzt
der muss in diesen wochen neue formulare
zur grundsteuer ausfüllen und zwar
eigentlich online
allerdings gibt es dabei ein
entscheidendes problem die entsprechende
internetseite der steuer plattform
elster ist völlig überlastet peter böhme
und anja klingen haben die details
meine steuer mache ich online so heißt
es auf der elster homepage der
finanzbehörden die grundsteuer aber
macht man hier derzeit nicht online
überlastung zu viele hauseigentümer
sowie reinhold um gisela wollen die
erklärung synchron steuer abgeben dazu
sind sie auch verpflichtet so ganz
einfach ist das aber nicht
ich finde es sehr schwierig weil wir
sind ja noch in der relativ glücklichen
lage so einigermaßen zu besser bescheid
zu wissen aber wenn ich meine
schwiegermutter denke die 85 jahre alt
ist niemand hat der ihr helfen kann
natürlich wir aber auch nicht bescheid
wissen in den meisten bundesländern
werden folgende informationen verlangt
neben den persönlichen daten werden
angaben zum gebäude abgefragt wie art
baujahr und wohnfläche des objekts dann
angaben zum grundstück wie lage und
größe oder auch der bodenrichtwert eine
größe zur wertermittlung des grundstücks
diese daten können zwar auch ein papier
anträgen erfasst werden aber eigentlich
soll die erhebung online erfolgen was
aber eben über elster momentan schwierig
ist
die plattform elster wird vom land
bayern betrieben nach unserem
kenntnisstand
wird bereits mit hochdruck an lösungen
gearbeitet
ich möchte auch noch darauf hinweisen
dass elster nicht das einzige produkt
ist es gibt mehrere möglichkeiten den
steuerlichen rechtlichen verpflichtungen
nachzukommen so gibt es auch eine seite
des
bundesfinanzministeriums grund
steuererklärung für privateigentum an
der nehmen aber nur elf der 16
bundesländer teil
steuererklärung online ist nicht immer
so einfach in deutschland ist
jetzt nach portugal da toben dutzende
waldbrände begünstigt werden sie seit
wochen durch anhaltende dürre und
extreme hitze mit temperaturen um 40
grad am schlimmsten ist die lage in der
region zwischen lissabon und porto und
im norden dort wüten die derzeit größten
brände 2 konnte die feuerwehr immerhin
ein dem 3000 hektar land sind jetzt
schon verbrannt thomas reichert mit mehr
nach wochen der trockenheit nach
hitzerekorden kommen nun die flammen
rund 1000 helfer kämpfen im zentrum und
im norden portugals mit rund drei
dutzend brände
tausende hektar wald ging schon verloren
spanien schickt löschflugzeuge
aber für dieses haus ein puffer flores
im landesinneren sind sie zu spät
und es kam ganz plötzlich viele rauch
und auf einer brannte das weiße haus wir
konnten nichts mehr machen
rund um die uhr versucht die feuerwehr
zu löschen
nachts leuchten die brände kilometerweit
angstvoll beobachtet von anwohnern die
darauf hoffen dass die feuer nicht noch
näher rücken
wir haben wasser bereitgestellt und
warten jetzt dass das feuer kommt wir
sehen dass es in unsere richtung kommt
bei der winzig gedreht hat sie werden
die ganze nacht aufpassen
schon anfang des jahres fiel kaum regen
eine aktuelle studie zeigt dass darin
das azorenhoch schuld ist dass im winter
über portugal und spanien hängen bleibt
dort soll es nun so trocken wie seit
1200 jahren nicht so die forscher der
premierminister warnt eindringlich vor
weiteren bränden
verursachen sie keine brände benutzen
sie keine maschinen in dieser woche ist
jede art von aktivität im wald verboten
portugal hat einem notfallplan
ausgerufen und blickt mit sorge auf die
kommenden tage
vorfreude und spannung steigen morgen
das zweite wm spiel der deutschen
fußballerinnen gegen spanien ein duell
das eine stammspielerin ungewollt am
fernseher verfolgen muss denn torjägerin
lehrer schüler eine frau mit der
erfahrung von 40 länderspielen ist
positiv auf das corona virus getestet
worden und deshalb ein häuslicher
isolation martina voss-tecklenburg
bricht nicht in panik aus dass sich
bielerinnen infizieren gehört für sie
zur neuen realität wenn die schützen des
2 0 gegen dänemark gegen den
vermeintlich stärksten gruppengegner
ausfällt dann ist das halt so es wird
auch noch weiter glaube ich mehr fälle
geben da müssen wir alle aktuell mit
klar kommt das allerwichtigste ist
schöner geht's gut und
als konsequenz ist natürlich so dass sie
morgen nicht bereit ist fürs team ob
lina magull nach leichten beschwerden
fit wird steht noch nicht fest die
schütze des führungstreffers wäre für
das deutsche team ein ähnlich großer
verlust wie für spanien der ausfall von
weltfußballerin alexia proteas doch auch
ohne diese wurde beim 4 1 gegen finden
dann deutlich die deutschen treffen
morgen auf starke gegnerinnen
heute um 21 uhr das gipfeltreffen in
gruppe a england gegen norwegen lena
kesting in brighton gewiss vor vollem
haus oder
genauso ist das norbert knapp 30.000
menschen werden heute abend das spiel
hier live verfolgen das war schon vor
monaten ausverkauft und dafür gibt es
gute gründe denn es verspricht ein sehr
spannendes spiel zu werden die
norwegerinnen die glänzen mit starken
schwimmerin und die engländerin die
wollen sich natürlich hier vor
heimischem publikum keine blöße geben
also es könnte ein offensiv spektakel
werden und wenn sie zu hause das auch
live verfolgen wollen dann lege ich
ihnen diesen sender hier ans herz und
zwar von 20 15 an lena vielen dank ich
bin auf jeden fall dabei das bisher
torreichste spiel dieser noch jungen
europameisterschaft haben gestern
frankreich und italien in rotterdam
geliefert und erfolgreichste torschützen
ist bis dato die französin grace kelly
euro sie erzielt für die equipe
tricolore drei treffer beim 5 1 gegen
überforderte
italienerinnen und
der australier ben oconnor im vorjahr
vierter der tour de france hat wegen
problemen am gesäßmuskel heute am
ruhetag seinen rückzug erklärt morgen
startet vorjahres regatta der poker mit
39 sekunden vorsprung auf den dänen
ringe ort in die zehnte etappe
simon geschke fährt im gepunkteten
trikot als führender der bergwerk
wertung alle corona tests von gestern
abend sind negativ ausgefallen
und das freut einen und eine noch immer
das stimmt danke schön norbert so zum
wetter gibt's von uns erst mal so viel
es gibt sommerliche wärme und wenig
regen mehr gleich von katja horneffer
das heute journal mit marietta slomka in
der halbzeitpause gegen 21 uhr 45 schön
dass sie dabei waren morgen sehen wir
uns wieder bis dahin schönen abend und
alles gute
[Musik]
guten abend die ganz große hitze kommt
in dieser woche noch nicht denn dieses
hoch zieht hier richtung mittelmeer und
das nächste hoch von den britischen
inseln sorgt auch dafür dass die
temperaturen in norddeutschland doch
eher nur mäßig warm bleiben die hitze
gibt es natürlich auch in spanien
portugal und in frankreich und ob die
hitze uns anfang der kommenden woche
wirklich erreicht müssen wir noch ein
bisschen abwarten noch aber freuen wir
uns über angenehme nacht temperaturen
bei denen wir gut lüften können bei 14
grad an der ostsee oder auch am main und
7 grad richtung lausitz oder auch im
südlichen brandenburg der himmel dazu
ist häufig klar hier im nordosten
genauso wie im südwesten sonst geht's
meist nur lockere wolkenfelder und auch
morgen wechseln sonne und wolken
freundlich miteinander ab und zwischen
berlin und der ostseeküste genauso wie
zwischen dem allgäu und im oberrhein
scheint die sonne zum teil auch
strahlend die höchsttemperaturen morgen
liegen zwischen 22 grad die richtung
niederbayern und auch in nordfriesland
und bis zu 31 grad an der börse und dann
wird es in den nächsten beiden tagen
erst mal wärmer am mittwoch erwarten uns
bis zu 35 grad am donnerstag ziehen dann
über den nordosten einige wolken hinweg
die etwas regen mitbringen und am
freitag kann es am alpenrand auch mal
für gewitter reichen schönen abend noch